Jared Polis Governor of Colorado and
Spencer Cox a Democrat and alleged
Republican have come together for some
sort of PSA you're halfway through your
second helping of mashed potatoes when
your Maga Uncle decides to share his
thoughts on the latest election
conspiracy
we all have that Uncle or instead of
passing the salt your woke niece passes
along a particularly controversial fact
that she read on social media most of
this you could say is basically harmless
it's just your standard cliches and
platitudes about oh why don't we all get
along and that's for the most part
that's what it is it's cringy it's
embarrassing all that but you can roll
your eyes and move on